elle va jouer un rôle clé dans la
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
qui ouvre ses travaux officiellement
demain au Palais d'Iéna elle est
sociologue elle s'appelle claire Toury
et on l'accueille après l'invitation
d'elle dans mon agenda on s'est un sujet
qui est très intime voilà on peut on a
tous un avis sur la fin de vie par un
avis on peut avoir un avis sur la forme
vie on peut y avoir été confronté de
près ou de loin donc ça touche l'affect
forcément c'est aussi un sujet sociétal
qui en dit aussi sur la manière dont on
fait société ensemble on ne
représentations collectives 150
Françaises et Français tirés au sort
pour travailler pendant plusieurs mois
sur la fin de vie avec cette question le
cadre d'accompagnement de fin de vie
est-il adapté aux différentes situations
rencontrées ou d'éventuelles changements
devraient-ils être introduit le cadre
actuel c'est la loi kless Leonetti elle
donne la possibilité d'une sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'à la mort
pour les malades atteints d'une
affection grave et incurable dont le
pronostic vital à court terme est
engagée mais les choses pourraient
évoluer à l'Assemblée une mission
d'information est lancée pour évaluer
cette loi dans son dernier avis le
Conseil consultatif national d'éthique
ouvre une voie pour une possible aide
active à mourir mais avec des conditions
très strictes Emmanuel Macron lui semble
tiraillé dans un en même temps devant
Line Renaud fervente partisane du droit
à mourir dans la dignité il semble être
prêt à changer la loi mais après une
rencontre avec le Pape pour qui
l'euthanasie est un péché le président
de la République est beaucoup plus
prudent claire Toury vous êtes une des
garantes de cet exercice de démocratie
participative avec des attentes mais
aussi des inquiétudes pouvez-vous
garantir aux citoyens choisis que leurs
paroles sera prise en compte
[Musique]
bonsoir claire Toury et merci d'être là
cette convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie est très attendue des Français
quelle place précisément aura-t-elle
dans le débat de société si sensible qui
s'ouvre alors la convention citoyenne
sur la fin de vie elle commence demain
elle est organisée par le CESU le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental et à l'heure à laquelle
je vous parle il y a 173 citoyens qui
sont attendus demain donc c'est assez
énorme et alors pour répondre à votre
question il y a un débat national sur la
fin de vie qui a commencé il y a
quelques temps avec la vie du CCNE
notamment le Conseil consultatif
national d'éthique merci beaucoup et
donc ce débat national il a plusieurs
contributeurs il y a des contributions
diverses qui vont l'alimenter et parmi
ces contributeurs il y a les citoyens
les citoyens qui vont l'alimenter à
travers la convention citoyenne sur la
fin de vie qui commence demain alors
parmi ces contributeurs ça veut dire
quoi ce mot ça veut dire que leur
conclusion ne sera pas forcément prise
en compte ils ne sont qu'une
contribution parmi d'autres alors ils
sont la contribution d'autres je dirais
plutôt ça comme ça c'est la pierre
angulaire en fait de du débat sur la fin
de vie qui est en train de s'ouvrir
forcément c'est la parole citoyenne qui
a beaucoup d'importance après ce ne sont
pas les citoyens qui vont faire la loi
et ça je crois que c'est important de le
dire tout de suite on leur dira demain
je j'en profite pour le rappeler il y a
des élus de la nation il y a des députés
des parlementaires il y a un
gouvernement il y a des gens qui sont là
pour prendre ses décisions mais les
citoyens des citoyens ils vont
contribuer à alimenter ce débat et le
fait qu'il ne fasse pas la loi ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas un cadre qui
est posé un cadre de redevabilité on
peut pas demander aux gens de donner 27
jours de leur vie puisque c'est quand
même 27 jours pour travailler sur un
sujet aussi sensible 27 jours est allé
sur combien de temps sur trois mois et
demi trois mois et demi viendront le
week-end au CES œufs Palais d'iénas à
Paris c'est ça du vendredi au dimanche
sur 9 weekends ça commence demain du
coup donc deux weekends en décembre 4 en
janvier février puis trois en mars et
donc c'est un engagement qui a très
important sur un sujet qui est
extrêmement important et extrêmement
sensible et donc on peut pas leur
demander de contribuer comme ça il y a
de la redevabilité j'entends le mot mais
c'est une contribution ce sont des
contributeurs vous ne répétez pas si je
puis dire ce qui s'était passé avec la
convention citoyenne sur le climat qui a
créé beaucoup de déceptions parce que la
parole la promesse présidentielle de
reprendre sans filtre ses conclusions
n'avaient pas été tenues la loi Claisse
Léonetti sur la fin de vie est-elle
adaptée ou doit-elle évoluer grosso modo
c'est la question à laquelle les 163
citoyens tir au sort vont devoir
répondre comment vont-ils parvenir
est-ce qu'ils vont être accompagnés
d'experts est-ce qu'ils vont faire des
auditions et si oui lesquelles alors la
question c'est est-ce que la loi classe
léonétienne est encore adaptée mais
c'est pas seulement ça la question vous
avez vu c'est pas le cadre légal c'est
le cadre de la fin de vie donc ça pose
d'autres questions mais que les citoyens
identifieront eux-mêmes et donc pour
vous répondre oui ils vont être
accompagnés il y a toute une équipe
autour c'est un dispositif et
précisément sur citoyenne il y a un
comité de gouvernance que j'ai la chance
de présider mais qui est composée de 14
personnes si représentant du ses œufs on
a aussi dans les représentants enfin
dans les membres du comité de
gouvernance deux représentants du Comité
consultatif national d'éthique dont son
président Jean-François delfreci on a la
directrice du Centre national des soins
palliatifs et de la fin de vie des
spécialistes de la participation
citoyenne des spécialistes de l'éthique
Cynthia Fleury notamment des anciens
citoyens de la convention climat donc
nous on est là depuis deux mois et demi
maintenant pour poser le cadre et puis à
ça ça ajoute toute une équipe
d'animateurs l'administration du CESU
des communicants enfin vraiment il y a
tout un dispositif qui a été pensé décès
il y a une cellule psychologique par
exemple qui va être mise à disposition
des citoyens puisque le sujet est quand
même
assez sensible et donc après c'est la
convention des citoyens dans un cadre
qui a été posé et on va pouvoir répondre
à leurs questions enfin la question qui
est posée ils vont faire des auditions
ils vont avoir accès à un socle
documentaire sauf que le documentaire
qu'on a construit pour eux voilà au sein
du comité de gouvernance et ce socle
documentaire il va être rendu public il
est sur le site internet internet de la
convention donc tout le monde peut y
avoir accès et voilà il y a des il y a
plusieurs auditions qui vont être
organisées les premières auront lieu ce
week-end et parmi les auditions on va
entendre à l'inclès qui viendra nous
présenter et genre Leonetti j'imagine
alors on a invité mais il est pas
disponible malheureusement mais on l'a
invité donc c'est Alain classe qui sera
présent et ils ont été tirés au sort
après un comment dire une sorte de
d'enquête qui fait que ceux qui ont été
des marchés consultés ces représentatifs
de l'ensemble des Français ça c'est
important d'expliquer c'est pas juste
tirage au sort parmi la population comme
ça alors c'est pas c'est ça c'est pas
les 173 premières personnes qui disent
oui qui vont être présentes pendant 9
weekends il y a des critères
géographiques sociologiques ces critères
géographiques catégories
socioprofessionnelles niveau de diplôme
l'âge le genre voilà des critères
basiques pas de critères excluants et
une fois qu'on croise tous ces critères
on a ces 173 citoyens qui représentent
la diversité de la population française
doivent-ils forcément se mettre encore
collectivement je crois à cette grande
question doivent-ils trouver une seule
réponse ou pas je crois pas vraiment je
crois pas que ce soit un préalable
indispensable peut-être qu'ils vont y
arriver moi il me semble que le sujet de
la fin de vie c'est avant tout un sujet
de controverse il s'agit pas de dire il
y a ceux qui ont tort il y a ceux qui
ont raison il s'agit de poser ensemble
les points de convergence les points de
divergence et parmi les points de
divergence
identifier ceux qui peuvent être
dépassés et ceux qui ne peuvent pas
l'être et le dire clairement je pense
que c'est ça qui est très important
quand il formuleront leur réponse alors
je sais pas quelle forme ça prendra mais
poser clairement ce sur quoi tout le
monde est d'accord et puis les questions
qui restent encore à trancher vous-même
vous êtes sociologue vous êtes
spécialiste des questions de
participation démocratie de
participative notamment pas du tout du
tout de ces sujets de fin de vie
d'euthanasie d'aide d'active à mourir
pourquoi vous avez accepté de diriger ce
comité de gouvernance alors moi je suis
sociologue de formation je suis plutôt
spécialiste des questions d'engagement
même pour être précis d'engagement des
jeunes mais je suis surtout présidente
du Mouvement Associatif qui est
l'organisation qui représente le monde
associatif en France et voilà quand et
je suis membre du 16e à ce titre là
c'était important que je vous soyez loin
de ce sujet professionnel c'était
important que je n'ai jamais pris aucune
position sur ce sujet c'était important
que je sois en capacité d'animer un
collectif et l'avantage de présider un
mouvement comme ça c'est le cas et puis
j'ai déjà eu une expérience au sein du
C2 puisqu'on avait travaillé avec des
citoyens il y a un an à peu près
justement sur les questions d'engagement
et de participation aux élections et
alors vous êtes garantes de quoi alors
la sérénité des débats c'est ça oui
alors je suis garante il y a des garants
qui qui sont s'appelle vraiment garant
moi je préside un comité de gouvernance
dont la mission est de s'assurer que ça
se passe bien que les citoyens trouvent
leur place qu'ils aient les réponses aux
questions qui sont posées fixez le cadre
les grands arbitrages méthodologiques je
vous le disais on a choisi de ne pas
avoir de critères excluants parmi le
panel mais on aurait pu choisir autre
chose donc on a fait ce choix là fixer
le rythme des sessions le nombre de
cessions fixé le découpage donc à trois
séquences une première séquence
appropriation et de rencontres une
deuxième séquence de délibération une
troisième séquence de restitution fixer
les premières auditions et puis après
s'assurer au quotidien que le débat soit
serein apaisé et dernier point l'un ce
qui est très important pour moi vraiment
j'insiste là-dessus c'est que notre
responsabilité c'est de s'assurer que
tous les points de vue sont entendus
surtout de ne pas alimenter une
polarisation de ne pas créer
d'humiliation et de faire en sorte que
voilà chacun quel que soit son
positionnement puisse être entendu de
façon équilibrée il y a beaucoup
d'instances
légitimes qui vont travailler sur le
sujet ici même à l'Assemblée nationale
vous avez une mission d'évaluation de la
loi classe Leonetti vous avez aussi une
mission sur la fin de vie qui va être
pilotée par Olivier Falorni ce qui est
un grand militant de la dactive à mourir
il ne s'en cache absolument pas il y a
cette convention citoyenne avec ses 173
tirés au sort et puis il y a le comité
d'éthique tout cela sa coexiste de façon
quoi égale où il y a une légitimité qui
qui est plus importante qu'une autre je
crois que chacun son rôle en fait je
pense que si on a aujourd'hui besoin
d'une convention citoyenne pour traiter
la question de la fin de vie ça veut
bien dire que malgré tout un tas
d'espace où il y a déjà eu des
discussions c'est peut-être pas
suffisant et donc poser les choses
prendre le temps c'est 27 jours d'une
vie un rendez-vous contre il y a peu de
gens qui peuvent passer 27 jours de leur
vie à parler d'un sujet comme celui-ci
sans être des professionnels de ce sujet
là donc prendre le temps poser les
choses poser les nuances poser les
différences les distinctions les
divergences etc c'est hyper précieux
hyper riche et ça va forcément aider la
rose pour faire avancer un pays tout
entier sur ce sujet la représentation
nationale devra trancher par la loi ou
le référendum peut-être que Emmanuel
Macron n'écarte pas encore totalement
cette option nous le verrons LCP voilà
accompagnera au plus près si possible
les travaux de ses citoyens tirés